le pire pour l'humanité vous pensez
qu'il est à venir
qu'il est derrière nous ou que ça peut
pas être pire qu'aujourd'hui
donc le style sous Kero c'est beaucoup
d'empereurs à la musique noire mais sans
perdre non plus le sens l'attachement
aux belles Cantos c'est comme ça qu'on
pourrait résumer un petit peu votre
votre musique d'une certaine façon alors
votre vrai nom c'est Aldo
Fornia Chiari
c'est compliqué et quand vous avez eu 6
ans la maîtresse à l'école vous a appelé
souk Karine c'est joli non ça veut dire
le petit morceau de sucre
c'est normal vous étiez quand même un
gros morceau de sucre
alors vous êtes né en 1955 en Emilie
Romagne la région la plus rouge du pays
c'est celle où Bertolucci a tourné 1900
famille de paysans communistes et vous
habitez face à une église qui est en
fait le seul endroit où vous pouvez
jouer de l'orgue gratuitement alors
évidemment quand vous rentrez à la
maison c'est un autre son de cloche
parce que chez vous c'était pas du tout
pro église d'ailleurs Adelmo c'est un
prénom qui n'est pas dans le calendrier
des saints et quand vous rentriez à la
maison vos parents parler de Marx de
Lénine de Mao Zedong et là il y a un
truc très rigolo pour nous les Français
un peu comme ce film fameux Don Camillo
et people c'est j'espère que le curé
c'est donc à Millau et chez lui c'est un
peu Pépone parce que effectivement votre
oncle était Maui
exactement alors question est-ce que
c'est le fait d'avoir été élevé dans une
famille très rouge très communiste voire
maoïs en face d'une église qui a fait
qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes devenu
anarchiste
j'ai toujours été
entre le sacré le profane
parce que
en grandissant j'ai vu à la fois toutes
les erreurs de l'église mais aussi
toutes les erreurs du communisme
alors vous passez votre enfance à Reggio
Emilia vous avez des beaux souvenirs de
nuit d'été en train d'écouter
Otis Redding et puis ensuite vous partez
en Toscane où vous formez vos premiers
groupes de rythme blues en 82 à 27 ans
vous faites pour la première fois le
Festival de San Remo en 83 votre premier
album qui s'appelle
umpo desucco et en 84 vous partez à San
Francisco
de partir aux États-Unis après je suis
revenu avec un disque que j'ai fait
là-bas et j'ai mis le nom d'un copain
plutôt que le mien et le disque a eu de
du succès mais c'était moi quand même
dû en fait se reprendre
et réussir à tenir mon contrat alors
effectivement quand on écoute ces
chansons on comprend bien ce mélange à
la fois de Racine noire et à la fois de
belles canto italiens alors sous quel
eau vous êtes le spécialiste des duos
vous avez fait des duos avec alors c'est
incroyable le nombre de gens avec qui il
a fait des duos avec Eric Clapton avec
Bibi King avec Joe Cocker avec Bono avec
Johnny Hallyday Mama avec Pavarotti avec
deux Part-Dieu j'ai fait une chanson
avec deux par Dieu qui s'appelle home
Piccolo ayude
pour barrière
[Applaudissements]
c'était une chanson pour aider le
professeur Montagnier
[Musique]
cette chanson en français et
si je me souviens bien
un petit coup de main voilà
a fait une très belle interprétation
très intense
du film 1900 de bertheluche et détourné
dans votre région vous avez fait des
duos avec chenet de Connor Tom Jones
Miles Davis un jour vous êtes sur une
île en vacances et Miles Davis vous
appelle et vous y croyez pas évidemment
il veut reprendre une chanson à vous
qu'il avait entendu complètement par
hasard et vous prenez un avion et vous
allez vous allez le voir à New York pour
pour jouer avec lui
un peu de récupérer les morceaux prisés
de mon mariage qui était en faillite
j'étais aux Maldives
m'a appelé à 4h du matin
[Musique]
penser que c'était une blague en fait
complètement tout de suite
j'ai perdu ma femme
mais je suis parti à New York
[Applaudissements]
qui veut dire les ailes d'or que vous
avez enregistrées avec Jenny Hooker peu
avant sa mort et vous l'avez vu
débarquer un jour qui est très âgé déjà
vous l'avez débarquer d'une limousine
avec deux superbes gonzesses et
lorsque je l'ai vu arriver avec ces deux
très belles filles
qui le réconfortait l'embrasser
que j'aurais bien aimé vivre comme lui
jusqu'à cet âge-là
alors justement maintenant vous êtes
retourné vivre dans une ferme un petit
peu comme vos parents vous avez des
chevaux des poulets des vaches vous
faites de l'huile vous faites du vin et
puis alors quand même c'est très chic
vous comparez votre vin avec celui de
Sting qui est votre voisin
deux par Dieu qui est devenu votre ami
vous êtes assez riche vous êtes sans
doute parmi les trois ou quatre
chanteurs les plus riches d'Italie mais
finalement quand vous êtes en tournée
vous vivez assez simplement et vous
dites moi finalement si j'ai du bon vin
et une femme en plus ça va
quelque chose qui nous permet de
communier des uns avec les autres qui
détend les tensions sans causer trop de
dommages et assurément moins de dommages
que la drogue et surtout Sylvain est bon
aussi qu'il est moins dommageable que
les femmes
justement
vous avez beaucoup souffert il faut le
dire vous avez une grosse déprime lors
de votre séparation avec votre femme
vous avez passé un an très très
difficile à prendre du Prozac et autres
tranquillisant
alors tu connais vraiment tout
c'est vrai vous êtes rencontrés quand
vous aviez 18 ans vous avez passé 12 ans
ensemble au début c'était un coup de fou
de formidable et puis peu à peu ben
voilà ça n'a pas pu résister au
calendrier comme vous dites et ça s'est
mal terminé vous avez beaucoup souffert
pour toujours d'ailleurs
pour moi
je l'aimais et elle m'aimait
mais on était incapable de vivre
ensemble
c'est le revers de la médaille de ma vie
de mon métier
je ne voudrais pas attirer la compassion
comme ça mais bon
[Applaudissements]
on va rester comme ça dans les dans les
vibrations noires on va vous faire une
interview cauchemar
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis prêt le pire cadeau de Noël
qu'on pourrait vous faire
des vacances avec le pape ou des
vacances avec
berlusconium
[Musique]
plutôt que mieux chez le pape que chez
berusconi mais Berlusconi fait peur en
ce moment aux Italiens parce qu'il
possède toutes les chaînes de télévision
les siennes plus les chaînes
gouvernementales puisqu'il est premier
ministre il fait voter des lois pour
enterrer ces magouilles précédentes il a
déclaré que la civilisation occidentale
était supérieure à la civilisation
musulmane est-ce que vous n'avez pas
peur en Italie de voir arriver un régime
non démocratique avec à sa tête qu'on
pourrait appeler un doute chez soft
oui c'est vrai que ça me préoccupe une
fois tu es à La Teste
comme la forme des Bénéteau mussolu elle
a une tête qui a tout à fait la forme de
celle de Mussolini
la pire des situations dans laquelle
vous pourriez vous trouver interview
cauchemar ça serait d'avoir un pétard
mais pas de feu du bon vin mais pas de
tire-bouchon ou une gonzesse super mais
pas de préservatif
ce serait d'avoir une femme qu'on est
préservative avec un préservatif
[Applaudissements]
c'est un portable qui sonne tout le
temps ou un portable qui sonne jamais
ah la cause
téléphone portable
[Rires]
le
plus grandir seul de vivre seul ou de
vieillir seul
de toute façon on est toujours seul
le pire ça serait de plus pouvoir
toucher votre maîtresse ou au contraire
de plus vouloir la toucher
ainsi
vouloir toucher sa maîtresse le pire
c'est d'être blasé très jeune ou
insatisfait à l'âge de la retraite la
cause
c'est de n'être vieux
comme beaucoup de gens qui pensent être
vivant mais qui en fait sont morts
le pire pour l'humanité vous pensez
qu'il est à venir
qu'il est derrière nous ou que ça peut
pas être pire qu'aujourd'hui non verra
nos causes
le pire c'est d'apprendre qu'on est
quitté par une lettre par un coup de
téléphone ou par quelqu'un d'autre donc
une femme
ni besoin de m'envoyer une lettre ni de
me le faire dire par quelqu'un d'autre
parce que moi je le sens qu'elle m'a
plaqué déjà six mois avant
[Musique]
l'album s'appelle shake et le premier
single s'appelle paella
merci zucchero merci beaucoup
votre vin avec Sting quelle vie terrible
à bientôt ciao et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de innarditude abonnez-vous
et mettez un pouce bleu